dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir creating
geometry for a computer game or a movie
is a very long and arduous task for
instance if we would like to populate a
virtual city with buildings it would
cost a ton of time and money and of
course we would need quite a few artists
this piece of work solves this problem
in a very elegant and convenient way it
learns the preference of the user then
creates and recommends a set of
solutions that are expected to be
desirable in this example we are looking
for tables with either one leg or
crossing legs it should also be properly
balanced therefore if we see any of
these criteria will assign a high score
to these models these are the
preferences that the algorithm should
try to learn
the orange bars showed a predicted score
for new models created by the algorithm
and larger value means that the system
expects the user to score this high and
the blue bars mean uncertainty generally
we are looking for solutions with large
orange and small blue bars this means
that the algorithm is confident that a
given model is in line with our
preferences and we get exactly what we
were looking for novel balance table
designs with one leg or cross legs
interestingly since we have these
uncertainty values one can also
visualize counter examples where the
algorithm is not so sure but would guess
that we wouldn't like the model it's
super cool that it is aware how
horrendous these designs look it may
have a better eye than many of the
contemporary art curators out there
there are also examples where the
algorithm is very confident that we are
going to hate a given example because of
its legs or unbalanced Ness and would
never recommend such a model so
indirectly it also learns how a balanced
piece of furniture should look like
without ever learning the concept of
gravity or doing any kind of
architectural computation the algorithm
also works on buildings and after
learning our preferences it can populate
entire cities with geometry that is in
line with our artistic vision excellent
piece of work thanks for watching and
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time